on n'a pas de table de cuisine depuis
qu'on a eus premier enfant
geneviève jamais les jean pierre girard
doivent rivaliser d'imagination pour
vivre à quatre ans leur condo de 915
pieds carrés la chambre des enfants
on a dit trouver des solutions un peu
créatif la venue imminente d'un
troisième enfant rendre la situation
encore plus compliquée on occupe 100 %
de l'espace et évidemment on est rendu
au bout de cet espace lovely trois dans
la même chambre
pas de garde-robe as quand même quand
nos amis d'abord lui vient nous visiter
ils en viennent pas de tout ce qu'on est
capable de faire
lorsque leurs voisins du dessus ont
vendu leur condo pour s'établir en
banlieue l'an dernier j'aime bien les
gens bien l'on acheté avec pour objectif
de fusionner les deux unités
mais leur projet pourrait jamais voir le
jour avec le règlement mais qui vient
d'arriver
ça faisait que ça nous empêcherait de le
faire et l'on serait contraint d'élever
nos trois enfants dans 915 pécari c'est
qu'une demi-douzaine d'arrondissement
montréal et ont déposé au cours des
derniers mois des projets de règlements
qui auront notamment pour effet
d'empêcher la fusion de deux unités de
logements ou plus ces projets de
règlements relève des arrondissements
mais elle découle d'une volonté de
l'administration plantes de protéger le
parc locatif de montréal
en fait l'objectif quand on s'est
concerté les arrondissements pour passer
ces règlements la mairesse a été très
claire elle souhaite avoir un équilibre
entre les métiers des familles sur l'île
de montréal mais aussi la protection des
locataires
certains estiment cependant que cette
stratégie va trop loin et qu'elle risque
de pousser de nombreuses familles vers
la rive-sud où la rive nord
on ne peut pas empêcher ce qui est
quelque chose qui fondamentale qui
s'appelle le droit de propriété en
disant aux familles
si vous n'êtes vous êtes intéressé à
voir plus grand et vous loger avec vos
enfants
là vous traversez le pont et vous
quitter montréal c'est inacceptable
une analyse démographique de la ville
publiée le mois dernier montre contre le
1er juillet 2018 et le 1er juillet 2019
montréal a perdu 8311 enfants de moins
de 10 ans durant la même période 15 1627
jeunes adultes âgés de 25 à 34 ans ont
quitté l'île de montréal généralement
pour s'établir dans les régions
adjacentes à la recherche de logement
plus vaste où plus abordable
l'administration plante soit très
freiner cet exode
un exercice particulièrement délicat
selon cette experte les arrondissements
ont fait un effort pour essayer de
trouver un juste milieu qui peut être
appliquée qui va faire en sorte de pot
chasser complètement les femmes est
propriétaire mais de maintenir en même
temps les femmes et le qatar dans les
quartiers les projets de règlement
interdisant la fusion de logement vise
surtout à protéger les triplex des
quartiers adjacents centre ville comme
le sud ouest
merci hochelaga maisonneuve rosemont la
petite patrie et les arrondissements de
verdun du plateau mont royal et de
villeray saint michel parc extension ont
aussi évoqué la possibilité d'empêcher
la fusion de logements dans les duplex
dans tous les cas il sera possible pour
les familles de demander une dérogation
mais le processus sera plus laborieux
qu'à l'heure actuelle dure toujours
possibilité pour les familles de pouvoir
fin ces fusions là mais par projet
particulier donc elles ne sont pas
interdites elles sont mieux encadrés
pour éviter les dérives justement à ce
niveau là aucun des projets de règlement
n'a encore été adoptée
geneviève et jean pierre garde donc
espoir que les arrondissements feront
marche arrière à l'instar de verdun qui
a retiré temporairement son projet de
règlement le temps de réévaluer la
question
la bataille des familles
c'est pas une bataille des locataires ou
d'époque et r faut pas diviser ces gens
là on est des montréalais on est des
femmes et on est ensemble il ya un
problème avec le parc immobilier un
problème avec le parc locatif ensemble
il faut qu'on réfléchisse à la question
mais il se prend pas sans un règlement
où on va nuire aux propriétaires
occupants qui on veut y arriver les
permis d'agrandissement est entêté gelés
dans villeray saint michel parc
extension
le couple a mis son projet immobilier
sur pause pour le moment il se
concentrera sur l'arrivée de cette
troisième criaient victoire qu dont
l'arrivée est prévue dans un mois ici
jérôme l'abbé radio-canada monde